intervenir ponctuellement sur deux
mécanismes la suspension provisoire de
plein droit de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale créée par la loi du 28
décembre 2019 et le retrait de
l'autorité parentale par les
juridictions pénales pour bien
comprendre les enjeux de ces
dispositions il convient de garder à
l'esprit que le retrait de l'autorité
parentale prive un parent de l'ensemble
de ses attributs y compris les plus
symboliques comme le droit de consentir
au mariage ou de consentir à l'adoption
de son enfant c'est donc la titularité
même qui est mise en cause le retrait de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
revient quant à lui a confié
exclusivement à l'autre parent le soin
de veiller sur l'enfant et de prendre
des décisions nécessaires pour sa santé
son éducation etc pour autant l'autre
parent conserve le droit d'entretenir
des relations personnelles avec l'enfant
via les droits de visite et
d'hébergement qui lui sont accordés sauf
motif grave apprécié par le JAF il
conserve aussi un droit de surveillance
qui l'autre parent à le tenir informé de
tous les choix importants relatifs à la
ville de l'enfant ceci étant rappelé
venant à la PPL dont nous sommes saisis
l'article premier propose tout d'abord
des tendres à la suspension provisoire
de plein droit de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale et des droits de
visite des bergement au cas de poursuite
ou de condamnation pour un crime ou une
agression sexuelle incestueuse commise
sur l'enfant la Commission a été
favorable à cette extension qui permet
de prendre en compte la situation de
l'enfant et non pas seulement celle de
l'autre parent se conformat ainsi au
souhait de lessivisme l'article premier
propose également de revoir les
conditions de durée au lieu d'une durée
maximale de 6 mois et d'une obligation
pour le procureur de la République de
série le JAF dans les 8 jours la
suspension courait jusqu'à la décision
de non-lieu la décision de la
juridiction du jugement ou jusqu'à la
décision du JAF s'il est saisi par le
parent poursuit sur cette question la
Commission a choisi de s'en tenir à la
position qu'elle avait adoptée en 2020
lorsqu'il avait été saisie d'amendement
similaire c'est-à-dire d'accepter une
suspension de plein droit mais
uniquement pour six mois et d'exiger une
intervention du juge pour la suite il
nous semble en effet disproportionné au
regard de la présomption d'innocence et
du droit de chacun de mener une vie
familiale normale de permettre une
suspension automatique tout le temps de
la procédure pénale qui peut durer
plusieurs années et sans intervention
obligatoire d'un juge seulement à
apprécier l'intérêt de l'enfant enfin
les députés ont créé un régime de
suspension distinct en cas de
condamnation pour des violences
volontaires ayant entraîné une ité de
plus de huit jours sur l'autre parent le
texte propose dans ce cas une suspension
provisoire de l'autorité parentale mais
uniquement si l'enfant a assisté au fait
la suspension vaudrait jusqu'à la
décision du cherche qui devrait être
saisie par l'un des parents dans les six
mois à compter de la décision pénale à
défaut le parent retrouverait l'exercice
de l'autorité parentale ce dispositif ne
nous a pas semblé cohérent à cause de la
condition liée à la présence de l'enfant
aura un enfant même non présent au
moment des violences que tout autant
ressentir la souffrance et l'insécurité
à cause de l'exclusion des violences
volontaires sur l'enfant lui-même enfin
il nous a semblé manqué d'intérêts
pratiques puisque les juridictions
doivent d'ores et déjà se prononcer sur
l'autorité parentale en cas de
condamnation pour cette infraction je
relève que les magistrats sont de plus
en plus sensibilisés sur l'importance
des mesures relatives à l'autorité
parentale et que le nombre de mesures
prononcées augmente ce dont on ne peut
que se réjouir l'article 2 de la PPL
prévoit ensuite de rendre plus
automatique sans toutefois l'imposer aux
chutes pénal le retrait de l'autorité
parentale en cas de condamnation pour un
crimin une agression sexuelle commise
sur l'enfant ou pour un crime commis sur
l'autre parent cette disposition elle le
mérite d’inciter plus fortement les
juges à prononcer à retrait total
d'autorité parentale en cas d'infraction
grave contre l'enfant ou l'autre parent
sans toutefois les privés de leur
liberté de moduler leurs décisions au
regard de l'intérêt de l'enfant à charge
pour eux de la motiver spécialement la
commission des lois en a revu permet
d'action afin de rendre le dispositif
plus intelligible et donc d'en favoriser
son implication par les juridictions
pénales elle a posé le principe du
retrait total de l'autorité parentale en
cas de condamnation pour un crimin ou
une agression sexuelle commise sur
l'enfant ou pour un crime commis sur
l'autre parent et l'obligation des
juridictions à se prononcer dans tous
les cas de condamnation d'un parent pour
crime ou des diplômés sur son enfant ou
pour crime commise sur l'autre parent
nous aurons tout à l'heure un débat sur
cette rédaction celle que nous avons
choisie à le mérite de la vérité
puisqu'elle expose clairement que le
juge concerne malgré tout sous réserve
une motivation spéciale la possibilité
de ne pas prononcer le retrait total
d'autorité parentale les formules du
type prononcent le retrait ou ordonne le
retrait nous semble de ce point de vue
plus relevé de l'affichage un article 2
bises de la PPL vise ensuite ajouter un
nouveau cas de délégation forcée de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale à un
tiers en cas de poursuite de mise à main
en examen ou de condamnation pour un une
agression sexuelle incestueuse
commission l'enfant par un parent qui
est seul titulaire de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale la commission y a
apporté un simple ajustement
rédactionnel la commission adoptait un
article additionnel de terre pour
instituer un répit pour l'enfant en cas
de retrait de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale et des trois de visiter
d'hébergement il prévoit qu'aucune
demande au JAF ne puisse être présentée
par le parent moins du 6 mois après le
jugement une disposition similaire
existe en cas de retrait de l'autorité
parentale et nous assemblés opportun de
le prévoir aussi en matière d'exercice
j'en arrive à l'article 3 qui vise à
procéder à diverses modifications dans
le code pénal à des fins de coordination
avec l'article 2 cet article nous a
semblé l'occasion de mettre fin au
décalage qui existe entre le Code civil
et code pénal en matière de retrait de
l'autorité parentale la rédaction
proposée introduirait une disposition
générale dans le code pénal applicable à
chaque fois qu'il y a condamnation d'un
parent pour de débit sur la personne de
son enfant ou l'autre parent je tiens à
saluer notre collègue Isabelle Santiago
député et remercie Marie merci pour le
travail qu'elle a fait sur cette PPL
notre rapporteur Anna à Rennes écrivait
le développement de l'enfant c'est la
continuité du monde l'enjeu de cette
proposition de loi et de faire en sorte
que les enfants ne soient pas
tributaires d'un passé douloureux marqué
par la violence entraînant des traumas
lourds les études les statistiques sont
glaçantes et sans équivoque 60% des
enfants témoins de violence développent
un stress post-traumatique 50% des
victimes de viol dans l'enfance on fait
une tentative de suicide psychiatre et
pédopsychiatre sont nombreux tel Muriel
Salmona et Louis salvarez a considéré
que les enfants qui se trouvent au cœur
des violences conjugales sont des
enfants qui développent des syndromes de
stress post-traumatique tout à fait
similaire aux victimes de guerre grâce
aux mobilisations des mouvements des une
association féministe les violences
faites aux femmes les féminicides ne se
plus ne sont plus considérés comme des
drames passionnelles mais comme la
résultante du système patriarcal qui
gangrène nos sociétés permettez-moi de
dénoncer à nouveau ici la culture du
viol de l'inceste véhiculés notamment
par l'industrie pornographique comme
nous l'avons analysé dans le rapport que
nous avons présenté au nom de la
délégation au droit des femmes et la PPR
adoptait à lui unanimité au début du
mois malheureusement les enfants restent
encore trop souvent des victimes
collatérales des objets de chantage de
la part de conjoint violents et malgré
les avancées législatives de 2019 et
2020 les enfants ne sont toujours pas
assez pris en considération mes chers
collègues non seulement nous devons
protéger les enfants témoins de violence
commises sur la personne de l'autre
parent en majorité la mère mais
également faire en sorte que plus aucun
enfant ne meurt des suites de
maltraitance aujourd'hui un enfant meurt
tous les cinq jours de maltraitance et
un an de la loi taquet nous pensons
toujours que les moyens accordés à la
protection de l'enfance ne sont pas
suffisants il est plus que temps d'agir
et nous saluons cette proposition de loi
qui s'inspire des recommandations de la
civisme qui va dans le bon sens et nous
tenterons de la renforcer par nos
amendements notamment à l'article
premier en suspendant l'autorité
parentale et pas seulement l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai toujours considéré qu'un
conjoint violent ne pouvait être un bon
père et je me réjouis que cette analyse
soit de plus en plus partagée la
vulnérabilité que présente les enfants
nous commandent une protection stricte
sans concession nous regrettons par
ailleurs que la présente proposition de
loi n'englobe pas tous les cas de
violence à l'encontre de l'enfant qui
quel que soit leur forme sont à dénoncer
ayant en tête que la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
nous oblige à protéger les enfants
contre toute forme de violence
d'atteinte ou de brutalité physique ou
mentale
avons-nous réellement au service de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et ce
d'autant qu'on le sait bien souvent les
enfants victimes de violences
reproduisent ces violences à l'âge
adulte avant de conclure je souhaiterais
monsieur le garde des sauts vous
interpellez car l'un de nos amendements
a été déclaré il recevable il nous
semble essentiels de faire évoluer
l'article de 127-5 du code pénal sur le
délit de non représentations d'enfants
il n'est plus possible que lorsqu'un
parent et en l'occurrence bien souvent
une mère craignant un danger tangible
pour l'enfant maltraitance attouchement
violence inceste tombe sous le coup de
ce délit il est impératif dans l'intérêt
de l'enfant d'appliquer le principe de
précaution de même il est grand temps
d'en finir avec le soi-disant syndrome
d'aliénation parentale utilisée trop
souvent lors de conflits et de violences
conjugales et je tiens ici à le dénoncer
et à le faire partager par l'ensemble de
mes collègues cette PPL est un pas
supplémentaire pour une meilleure
protection des enfants en cas de
violence nous la voterons en espérant
qu'elle puisse encore être améliorée par
nos amendements je vous remercie
petit cher collègue c'est à présent le
tour de la présidente Annick billon qui
a 8 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
madame la députée auteur de cette
proposition de loi enfin enfin
l'immeuble lien entre parents et enfants
peut-être considéré comme délétère
lorsque le parent est violent que
d'année perdu que de vie abîmée pour
n'avoir pas su dissocier le père du mari
la femme de la mère avoir nié les
vidence qu'un mari violent car c'est
souvent un mari est un homme violent un
père violent non un enfant ne peut pas
se construire de façon équilibrée dans
un climat de violence même si cette
violence n'a exercé que sur la mer cela
constitue une violence pour l'enfant une
violence psychologique l'enfant est pris
dans un étau entre son père et sa mère
impuissant pour sa propre sécurité face
à un conflit qui pour reprendre les
termes du juge Édouard Durand
s'apparente à une scène de guerre un
attentat pire même car dans un une
guerre ou un attentat l'enfant peut se
réfugier dans les bras d'un de ses
parents l'enfant n'a d'autre choix que
de se taire d'assister impuissant aux
délitement des piliers de son existence
cette violence psychologique aura
indéniablement des conséquences graves
sur son développement sur l'enfant qu'il
est et sur l'adulte qu'il deviendra
protéger l'enfant c'est donc l'éloigner
de cette violence quitte à suspendre
l'autorité parentale qui rappelons-le
vise à protéger l'enfant dans sa
sécurité sa santé et sa moralité pour
assurer son éducation et permettre son
développement dans le respect du à sa
personne l'autorité parentale est une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'enfant un
devoir un parent violent n'est pas un
bon parent de nombreuses études montrent
qu'un père violent se sert des enfants
pour nuire de la mer car c'est souvent
la mère la victime comme une monnaie
d'échange y compris après la séparation
l'autorité parentale qui que peut
exercer le parent violent condamné
soumet enfant à une pression insidieuse
perverse qui ne permet pas à l'enfant de
se reconstruire qui confronte la mer à
un danger permanent aujourd'hui le
bourreau dicte encore sa loi et que dire
de la violence directe de l'inceste à ce
titre je tiens à saluer tout
particulièrement le travail et
l'engagement de longue date sur ce sujet
de notre rapporteur Marie Mercier la
commission des lois a fait le choix de
permettre la suspension en urgence avant
tout jugement de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale d'un parent mis en
cause pour les infractions les plus
graves sur son enfant crime viol
agression sexuelle
je comprends cette position équilibrée
qui entend concilier présomption
d'innocence et protection de l'enfant je
souhaite que nous puissions aller plus
loin plus que l'exercice de l'autorité
c'est bien l'autorité parentale en tant
que telle qu'il faut suspendre car le
parent privé de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale reste néanmoins titulaire de
cette autorité ainsi le parent poursuivi
mis en examen ou condamné pour des faits
graves conserve certains attributs
fondamentaux de l'autorité parentale
comme le droit de surveillance de
l'enfant il est important de corriger
cette situation nous devons être plus
ambitieux pourquoi ne pas élargir
l'article premier aux attentes sexuelles
incestueuses nous aurons l'occasion d'en
rediscuter madame la rapporteur je me
félicite également du choix de la
commission des dictées en principe de la
suspension du droit de visite et
d'hébergement dans le cadre d'un
contrôle judiciaire pour violence
familial c'est là aussi une mesure de
cohérence qui aura pour effet
d'acculturer les juges et les inciter à
porter un nouveau regard sur ces
dossiers complexes en tant que
présidente de la délégation au droit des
femmes et auteurs de la proposition de
loi visant à protéger les jeunes mineurs
des crimes sexuels devenus une loi
enrichie par le Parlement et vos travaux
madame la rapporteur je me félicite des
avancées proposées aujourd'hui
et à la fois par vous et par la
commission des lois ce texte marque bien
le début d'un changement profond dans
notre manière d'appréhender les
violences intrafamiliales et aussi
d'accompagner les victimes pour conclure
parce que lorsqu'on est à la tribune on
pense aussi aux gens qu'on peut recevoir
j'ai une pensée pour une maman de trois
enfants qui m'a sollicité pour la
première fois il y a quelques mois ses
enfants ont été victimes d'inceste cette
mère comme beaucoup d'autres a besoin de
l'aide de la justice pour éloigner ses
enfants de leur père je lui emprunterai
ces mots les enfants sont l'avenir
protégeons les et pour l'instant on y
arrive pas
le groupe Union Centris votera bien
entendu ce texte et j'en profite pour
saluer le travail de la sénatrice
Dominique Verrien qui devait être à
cette tribune également sénatrice en
mission sur le traitement judiciaire des
violences intramidales nous attendons
leur conclusion pour avancer sur ces
sujets monsieur le garder sceaux je vous
remercie pour votre attention je
voudrais saluer également Isabelle
Santiago l'autrice de la proposition de
loi que je remercie d'avoir initié cette
proposition de loi et j'en profite pour
remercier aussi la Chancellerie qui a
fait bien compris travailler avec elle
sur ce texte je voudrais à cet instant
émettre trois regrets mon premier regret
et que le la portée de cette proposition
de droit était restreinte par la
commission des lois premier regret
deuxième regret c'est la méthode du
patchwork de proposition de loi sur ces
sujets où nous avançons PPL par PPL on
en est à l'âge pour bien quatrième en 4
ans nous ont et à chaque fois on il y a
des trous énormes dans la raquette et
j'aurais pas un autre regret quand même
que si je vais exprimer c'est que je on
va voter là des dispositions qui ont été
refusées il y a moins de deux ans par
amendement porté par mes collègues et
moi-même et ascendant d'entre nous qui
n'avait pas eu le bonheur de plaire à
l'époque à la commission des lois mais
qu'on va voter aujourd'hui pendant ce
temps-là ont perdu du temps et on aurait
besoin d'une belle grosse ou grande loi
sur la protection des femmes et des
enfants sur les violences
intrafamiliales ceci étant dit j'aurais
vous raconter
rapidement ce que je vis il ne se passe
pas une semaine pas une semaine sans que
je sois saisie deux dossiers
qui me sont apportés par des mères ou
par des avocats qui concerne c'est
toujours la même histoire ça commence
par une séparation entre les parents le
quasiment à chaque fois la mer est
partie elle a quitté le père le père a
été très blessé dans son orgueil de
cette abandon qu'il a vécu la séparation
spasmale et c'est au tour des enfants
que ce cristallise le conflit poste
séparation entre les parents au bout de
quelques temps et je pense ce sera un
sujet intéressant à étudier les enfants
rentrent des week-end chez le père en
racontant des comportements incestueux
qui n'avaient pas été commis avant ce
qui se passe quelque chose là monsieur
le garde des sceaux il faut qu'on s'y
intéresse et raconte des comportements
incestueux
mon sentiment c'est que le père se venge
de la mer en allant porter là où ça fait
la plus grande souffrance à une mère
c'est à dire en commettant des
agressions sexuelles sur les enfants la
mère va porter plainte commence pour
elle le chemin de croix c'est un chemin
de croix parce que le doute profite
toujours à l'accusé au Père ce sont des
affaires compliquées je connais un cas
dans lequel le juge a dit madame je sais
que vous dites la vérité que votre
enfant dit la vérité je ne peux rien
faire d'autre que de vous recommander de
la renvoyer en week-end chez le père
pour qu'on puisse mieux établir la
matérialité des faits se mêle les
experts alors là arrive le syndrome
d'aliénation parentale qui a été évoqué
par mes collègues les experts et en
général ça se finit par le fait que la
mer est une manipulatrice affabulatrice
qui transforme la parole de l'enfant le
père est une victime la mère finit par
ne pas vouloir envoyer l'enfant en
week-end chez le père parce que c'est un
lieu où l'enfant est exposé à des
comportements incestueux le père se
retourne contre la mer avec le délit de
nous représentation d'enfants et des de
nombreuses femmes alors bien sûr je ne
connais que le train qui arrive en
retard je ne sais pas tout ce qui se
passe bien cela on en parle pas j'espère
qu'il y en a monsieur le garde des
sceaux mais ces cas-là sont légions ces
femmes vivent des enfers judiciaires et
certaines partent à l'étranger avec
leurs enfants parce qu'elles n'ont que
cette solution là pour s'en sortir voilà
je voulais vous raconter ça parce que on
a besoin de répondre à ces situations là
mieux qu'on y répond aujourd'hui c'est
de la maltraitance institutionnelle qui
est infligée aux femmes et aux enfants
et nous sommes beaucoup trop frileux mes
chers collègues beaucoup trop frileux
pour répondre à
cette souffrance énorme qui ce que
vivent les femmes les femmes et les
enfants et là on va faire encore un
petit pas alors je voulais dire monsieur
le garde des sceaux soin de dénon
représentation d'enfant merci pour la
circulaire pour le décret du 23 novembre
2021 ça a déjà un peu arrangé les choses
mais maintenant il faut aller plus loin
supprimer les énigmes représentation
d'enfants qui ne sert qu'on perd de même
quand est-ce qu'on va discuter du fait
que les pères qui n'effectue pas le
droit de visiter d'hébergement n'ont
aucune sanction aucune amende civile
mais alors quand une mère ne remet pas
l'enfant le weekend elle peut se
retrouver l'objet de tous les
harcèlements du père et vous raconte pas
ce qu'on les appelle les enfants à la
fenêtre ces enfants qu'attendent le père
tous les week-ends et qui vient pas
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen qu'il
a trouvé pour empêcher la mère de sortir
le week-end voilà nous avons tout ça je
conclus peut-être monsieur le Président
pour dire que
j'y arrive j'arrive pour dire que los
and Daniel nations parentale il y a une
circulaire qui a été faite en 2017 à
l'égard des magistrats ils ne disent pas
syndrome d'Aya son parental ils disent
mère manipulatrice maintenant donc c'est
un problème de culture et il faut aller
les chercher par la culture du milieu
merci
Monsieur Philippe mouillé et le dernier
intervenant
également pour 4 minutes
c'est le président de féministe madame
la rapporteur monsieur le Président de
la Commission la proposition de loi que
nous examinons comme cette idée vise à
mieux protéger des offres victimes de
violence intrafamiliale le 9 février
2023 cette PPL était adopté à la somnie
nationale à l'unanimité le gouvernement
n'a pas déclaré de procédure accélérée
sur un texte traitant d'un sujet aussi
sensible que la protection de l'enfance
qui nécessite que toutes les précautions
soient prises par le législateur ainsi
nous constatons que le contenu de ce
texte a fait l'objet de modification à
chaque lecture depuis son dépôt jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit examiné aujourd'hui en
séance par le Sénat
cette proposition de loi se situe entre
dans la droite ligne de la loi du 28
décembre 2019 visant à agir contre les
violences au sein de la famille ce texte
a introduit dans notre droit une
distinction entre le retrait de
l'autorité parentale est celui de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale la
PPL que nous examinons vise à élargir le
mécanisme de suspension provisoire de
plein droit de l'exercice de cette
autorité parentale dans le cadre des
procédures pénales et à rendre plus
systématique le prononcé de retrait de
l'autorité parentale par les
juridictions pénales en cas de crime
commis sur la personne de l'enfant ou
l'autre parent ou d'agressions sexuels
incestueuses
depuis 2016 le nombre d'actes de
violences attraphémiennes ne cessent
d'augmenter en 2019 44% des plaintes
pour violence physique et sexuelles
enregistrées par les services de
sécurité concernent des violences
commises au sein de la famille avec le
confinement l'année 2020 a connu un pic
mais la tendance à la hausse ne sent pas
fléchir comme le prouve les chiffres
enregistré depuis 2021 la libération de
la parole est l'encouragement à signaler
toutes les formes de violences
intrafamiliales ont sans doute
contribuer à cette augmentation
mais ces chiffres effrayants derrière
lesquels il convient de mettre des
visages nous oblige en autre qualité de
législateur nous devons agir afin
d'enrayer ce phénomène je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer le travail minutieux
de réécriture de cette proposition de
loi par notre rapporteur Marie Mercier
qui maîtrise parfaitement ces mécanismes
juridiques complexes il y a déjà
beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet des
violences conjugales et intrafamiliales
je la rejoins dans son choix de limiter
notre intervention à améliorer les
dispositifs que sont la suspension
provisoire de plein droit de l'exercice
de l'autorité parentale et le retrait de
cette autorité par les juridictions
pénales
les respects des principes généraux du
droit constitutionnel et conventionnelle
que sont la présomption d'innocence
l'intervention nécessaire du juge
impression il concrètent l'intérêt de
l'enfant le droit à une vie familiale
est privée normale à très certainement
guidé le travail de réécriture par la
commission des lois de plus les
amendements adoptés par la Commission
ont permis de rationaliser et de mettre
de la cohérence entre le droit civil et
le droit pénal ainsi l'article premier
l'amendement adopté réserve l'extension
de la suspension de plein droit de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
aux cas les plus graves de crimes ou des
réseaux sexuels incestueuses sur les
personnes de l'enfant une mesure qui
permettra d'ailleurs de suspendre
d'urgence avant tout jugement l'exercice
de l'autorité parentale d'un parent mis
en cause pour les infractions les plus
graves sur son enfant le temps qu'un
juge se prononce
la Commission a considéré que la
suspension automatique tout le temps de
la procédure qui peut durer des années
mais oui on le sait semblait
disproportionnées au regard de la
présomption d'innocence et du droit de
chacun de mener une vie normale
l'article 2 propose de faire du retrait
total de l'autorité parentale le
principe en cas de crime ou d'agression
sexuelle incestueuse d'un enfant ou de
crime sur l'autre parent enfin l'article
4 contribuera à mettre plus de cohérence
et rendre effective les mesures adoptées
dans cette proposition de loi ainsi
modifier et j'ai résumé les
interventions l'action de la commission
des lois permet à ce que ces
propositions de loi viennent améliorer
les dispositifs juridiques existants
afin de les rendre plus effectifs dans
le but d'une meilleure protection des
enfants victimes de parents violents
ainsi de modifier naturellement le
groupe les républicains votre as
proposition de loi je remercie
[Applaudissements]
avant la clôture de la discussion
générale monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole pour vos observations après la
discussion des collègues merci monsieur
le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
m'adressais en particulier madame la
sénatrice
Rossignol et à Madame la signatrice
Cohen
je regrette comme vous madame la
sénatrice
ce que vous avez appelé le côté un peu
patchwork
mais convenait avec moi que nous n'avons
pas le don de médiumnité et qu'il faut
au fur et à mesure
s'adapter aux évolutions parfois
terrifiantes d'ailleurs de notre société
de notre époque
au fond c'est pas le droit qui fait la
société c'est la société qui fait le
droit
parce que vous décrivez tout à l'heure
on l'a déjà évoqué ensemble devant la
délégation droit des femmes
je vous remercie d'avoir rappelé que
vous aviez attiré mon attention sur les
enfants témoins dont j'ai souhaité donc
nous avons souhaité faire des enfants
victimes parce que quand vous êtes
témoin d'une scène où votre père tabasse
votre mère et que vous êtes un tout
petit vous n'êtes pas un témoin vous
êtes effectivement une victime nous
l'avons fait
reste la question de des poursuites pour
non-reprées
j'entends ce que vous dites
c'est sans doute souvent ce que vous
décrivez pas toujours pas toujours et
c'est là où il faut être prudent mais
très souvent et dans l'hypothèse que
vous décrivez c'est une hypothèse
terrifiante pour une maman que de devoir
au fond livré à son bourreau
son enfant
vous le savez mieux que moi les
recevabilité n'a pas de signification
sur le fond
ça n'est pas parce que
tel amendement est considéré comme
irrecevable pour des questions de droit
que nous ne sommes pas les uns et les
autres préoccupés par la question et je
vous prends madame la rapporteur à
témoin je vous promets qu'on va y aller
sur cette question j'attends simplement
ça n'est pas anormal le rapport vérien
Chandler qui arrive qui reprend
évidemment cette question c'est une
question importante il faut
effectivement que l'on puisse protéger
les femmes
qui n'écoutant que
ma couleur amour maternel au fond ne je
reprends cette expression ne livre pas
leur enfant au père quand elles savent
que il exerce sur l'enfant des des
violences et des choses inadmissibles il
faut en même temps être respectueux des
règles constitutionnelles c'est bien le
moins de la présomption d'innocence mais
on y travaille on y réfléchit et je vous
ai dit d'ailleurs devant la délégation
droit des femmes lorsque vous m'aviez
auditionné que nous irions sur ce sujet
et je vous redis madame la sénatrice
Rossignol je dis également à madame la
sénatrice Cohen qui a la même
préoccupation mais c'est au fond une
préoccupation qui nous est commune que
nous aboutirons sur cette question parce
qu'elle est fondamentale et
elle
met en exergue et en évidence dans les
situations que vous évoquez au fond un
traitement qui est un traitement
totalement injuste et je pense que
niveau ni il garde des sceaux ne peuvent
accepter l'idée qu'une telle injustice
puisse se perpétrer mais il faut que
nous attendions avec recul prudence les
travaux qui vont nous arriver et dont je
sais d'ores et déjà qu'ils sont de
grandes qualités
puisque si j'en juge par le nombre de
d'intervenants qui ont été
entendus et puis nous savons le
l'engagement de la député Chandler de la
sénatrice Verrien sur ces questions et
moi j'ai la conviction que une rapport
de très grande qualité nous sera remis
prochainement et que nous pourrons
ensemble en tirer toutes les
conséquences au moment de commencer
l'examen de l'article premier qui est
relatif à suspension provisoire de
l’exercice de l'autorité parentale je
souhaiterais juste rappeler que
lorsqu'un enfant est en danger la
question de l'autorité parentale ou de
son exercice ne vient que dans un second
temps puisque dans un premier temps il
s'agit de naître l'enfant à l'abri c'est
ça l'urgence il existe alors plusieurs
procédures possibles bien souvent à la
main du parquet qui joue un rôle central
en amont de toute poursuite il peut
ordonner en urgence et sans aucune
procédure contradictoire le placement
provisoire de l'enfant éventuellement
chez l'autre parent à charge pour lui de
saisir le juge des enfants dans un délai
de huit jours il peut placer aussi dans
un lieu de placement pour enfants en
danger encore faut-il qu'il y ait des
places le parquet peut également à tous
les stades de la procédure ou même en
amont recueillir la délivrance d'une
ordonnance de protection auprès du JAF
avec des mesures d'interdiction d'entrée
en relation et de se rendre dans
certains lieux où la suspension du droit
de visite et d'hébergement enfin dans le
cadre d'une information judiciaire ou de
procédure rapide de jugement la personne
poursuivie peut faire l'objet d'un
contrôle judiciaire ou d'une assignation
à résidence sous surveillance
électronique là encore peut être
prononcé une interdiction d'entrée en
contact et de paraître en certains lieux
où la suspension du droit de visite et
d'hébergement de l'enfant mineur il faut
donc garder à l'esprit mes chers
collègues que ces dispositifs se
cumulent et que la mise à l'abri de
l'enfant à proprement parler ne repousse
pas sur les deux articles 378 2 et 378
du Code civil dont nous discutons
actuellement
merci Madame billon a également
l'inscription sur l'article merci
monsieur le Président le dispositif
initial de l'article 1 vis à créer un
régime spécifique en cas de condamnation
même non définitif pour des violences
volontaires et entraîner une idée de
plus de 8 jours lorsque l'enfant a
assisté au fait je rejoins la rapporteur
sur le point suivant il n'y a pas de
raison de conditionner cette mesure au
fait que l'enfant est assisté aux
violences selon leur juge toujours
Édouard DURAND président de la civisme
le rajout de cette condition de présence
de l'enfant lors des faits diminue de 4
à 5 fois le nombre de dossiers à traiter
or nous ne sommes pas ici pour réduire
le nombre de dossiers aux dépens des
victimes et bien pour renforcer la
protection des enfants j'en profite donc
pour remercier Madame la rapporteur
d'avoir pris en considération cet
amendement que j'avais déposé en
commission et donc qui a été intégré au
texte je pense toutefois qui les
fondamental de tenir compte des
violences conjugales et non uniquement
des crimes commis sur l'autre par comme
motif de suspension de l'autorité
parentale ou de son exercice nous devons
consacrer la formule un parent violent
ne peut pas être un bon parent cela est
d'ailleurs l'un des objectifs visés par
l'amendement que je vous présenterai
dans quelques instants en effet
l'article 1 tel que rédigé ne permet pas
une prise en compte globale de la
problématique des femmes victimes de
violences conjugales et un très
sacrement des enfants victimes de
violence intrafamiliale je vous remercie
très bien maintenant nous commençons sur
l'article premier par 8 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
et nous commençons par l'amendement 22
présenté par Madame Cohen
oui merci monsieur le Président comme je
voulais déjà dit lors de mon
intervention générale nous souhaitons
aller plus loin dans la protection des
enfants nous proposons donc de retirer
l'autorité parentale et non simplement
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale du
parent poursuivi par le ministère public
mais en examen par le juge d'instruction
ou condamné même non définitivement pour
un crime commis sur la personne de
l'autre parent ou pour une agression
sexuelle incestueuse ou atteinte
sexuelle incestueuses ou un crime commis
sur la personne de son enfant jusqu'à la
décision du juge aux affaires familiales
nous proposons nous avons donc ici
rétabli la version adoptée à l'Assemblée
nationale pour que ces dispositions
durent pendant toute la procédure pénale
cela nous paraît bien plus protecteur
madame la rapporteur nous proposons
également d'étendre ces dispositions à
l'ensemble des violences volontaires
commises dans le cadre conjugal ou poste
séparation et nous regrettons vraiment
ce sens cette suppression par la
Commission des lois et d'ailleurs nous
ne la comprenons pas il est primordial
de préserver les enfants victimes dans
ce laps de temps d'enquête le doute doit
profiter à la protection de l'enfant
nous ne devons pas prendre le risque un
acte de nature pénale soit commis à
l'encontre de l'enfant pendant ce temps
de latence mes chers collègues la simple
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale ne suffit pas à protéger
efficacement les les enfants victimes de
violences conjugales ou un train
familial en effet dans ce cas écoutez
bien l'autre parent a obligation
d'informer le parent poursuivi pour
violence du lieu du nouveau domicile de
l'école il doit également rester informé
des choix importants relatifs à la vie
de l'enfant ce n'est pas pour nous
acceptable je vous appelle donc à
soutenir notre amendement pour réécrire
cet article premier dans un sens ce qui
nous semble beaucoup plus protecteur je
vous remercie
ensuite nous avons l'article
l'amendement 44 rectifié bis c'est
Madame guidez qui présente
bilan qui est identique
entendu alors donc monsieur le Président
ma collègue Dominique verrière et
moi-même proposant une nouvelle
réécriture de cet article premier en
conservant les deux dispositifs
introduits entre temps par l'amendement
de Madame la rapporteur Marie Mercier
l'objectif poursuivi étant d'aboutir à
une rédaction juridique complète de
l'article 378 alinéa 2 l'amendement que
nous présentons prévoit une suspension
de plein droit de la titularité de
l'autorité parentale et non simplement
de son exercice la distinction entre
exercice et titularité et primordiale un
parent titulaire de l'autorité parentale
maintient des relations personnelles
avec l'enfant et conserve un droit de
surveillance sur ce dernier le parc le
parent poursuivi mis en examen ou
condamné conserve donc certains
attributs fondamentaux de l'autorité
parentale nous souhaitons corriger cette
situation et nous estimons qu'il est
nécessaire de prendre en compte toutes
les violences sexuelles incestueuses
commisses à l'encontre d'un enfants nous
souhaitons étendre les cas de retrait
provisoire de plein droit de l'autorité
parentale du parent poursuivi ou
condamnés au délit de l'atteinte sexuel
incestueuses la notion d'atteinte
sexuelle permet d'englober un plus grand
nombre de cas dans lesquels l'enfant est
victime d'inceste et ainsi de lui
assurer une meilleure protection une
agression sexuelle est une atteinte
sexuelle non consentie enfin et comme je
l'expliquais à l'instant cet amendement
permet de prendre en considération les
condamnations pour violence conjugales
et non uniquement les crimes commis par
un parent à l'égard de l'autre parent
sans les conditionner à un nombre de
jours minimum 10 tt ou à la présence de
l'enfant il n'est pas question
d'attendre que le parent tue l'autre
parent avant de mettre à l'abri le ou
les enfants la protection des enfants
doit nous guider je vous remercie
très bien ensuite madame Haribo vous
pouvez présenter successivement vos deux
amendements 25 et 26 c'est ce que
j'allais vous proposer monsieur le
Président merci de cette proposition
donc avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
manifester notre notre attachement comme
nous l'avons dit en dans la dans la DG à
la rédaction proposée par l'Assemblée
nationale ça nous semble
particulièrement intéressant et ça nous
semble rester fidèle à l'idée originelle
de du texte et il nous semble que dans
les propos du garde des sauts on a
ressenti la même la même intention
nous défendons donc une absence de
limitation de la suspension de cet
exercice c'est des droits de visite et
d'hébergement ce qui nous semble
impérieux en cas de poursuite ou de
condamnation pour des faits criminels ou
d'agressions sexuelles commises sur son
enfant cette suspension doit accorder le
bénéfice d'une protection durable et
j'ai souligné dans la DG que ça pouvait
durer longtemps nous considérons
également que les viol ences conjugales
sont trop massives et trop lourdes de
conséquences sur les enfants qui en sont
victimes pour ne pas conduire à la
suspension de l'autorité parentale et
des droites visites et d'hébergement
pour faciliter le travail des juges et
éviter une limitation excessive de la
portée du texte sur cet aspect nous
proposons donc de rétablir la version
transmise par l'Assemblée nationale
concernant l'amendement de qui est un
amendement de 26 qui est un amendement
de repli nous souhaitons rendre possible
une réécriture de l'article premier
incluant les violences conjugales à
partir de 8 jours ditté et le crime ou
l'agression sexuelle commis sur son
enfant sans délai maximal de suspension
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
dans ce dernier cas de figure nous
considérons que ces deux dispositions
constituent un des apports majeurs de la
proposition de loi et nous souhaitons
que l'article premier retrouve l'esprit
de sa rédaction initiale merci
entendu ensuite nous avons deux
amendements identiques le premier et le
numéro 3 présenté par Madame Vogel oui
merci monsieur le président donc comme
évoqué lors de la de la discussion
générale le texte qui a été adopté en
commission notamment dans son article 1
que nous discutons et revenus sur
plusieurs mesures protectrices qui
avaient pourtant été adoptées à la
semaine nationale donc cet amendement il
vise au rétablir deux premièrement
permet de la suspension de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale pour certaines
violences graves jusqu'à ce que la
justice statue vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
la loi limite cette suspension à 6 mois
même dans les cas où elle est intervenue
parce que le parent est poursuivi par le
ministère public mise en examen ou
condamné pour un crime commis sur
l'autre parent pour agression sexuelle
incestueuse ou pour un crime comique
entre son enfant et donc si la justice
est trop lente et qu'elle prend plus de
6 mois ce qui malheureusement peut
arriver et bien l'enfant après 6 mois et
de nouveau en danger
le deuxième le deuxième dispositif que
l'amendement rétablit c'est la
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale et du droit de visite pour le
parent condamné pour des violences
volontaires ayant conduit un incapacité
totale de travail de plus de 8 jours si
l'enfant assistait au fait je crois que
ça a été dit déjà par de nombreuses
collègues avant moi on sait très bien
que lorsqu'un enfant assiste à une
violence qui on est là dans un cas très
grave puisqu'il interruption de travail
depuis 8 jours et bien voilà ce sont des
faits de violence extrêmement forts
l'enfant n'est pas ça a été dit témoin
il est il est victime et il est évident
que il en aura à souffrir toute sa vie
et donc dans ces cas-là il paraît
important de suspendre l'autorité
parentale les droits de visite et
d'hébergement du parent condamné pour de
telles faits jusqu'à ce que juste à
faire familial statut sur l'autorité
parentale je vous remercie
pour le moment comparable
c'est un amendement comparable nous
sommes prêts à une réintroduction de la
condition selon laquelle l'enfant doit
avoir assisté au fait pour que
l'exercice de cette autorité soit
suspendue lorsque des violences sont
commises sur l'autre parent tout en
soulignant quand même que c'est un
premier pas et que le fait de ne pas
avoir assisté peut aussi constituer une
violence parce que ça va bien au-delà et
le 28
nous nous donne l'occasion en fait de
focaliser une nouvelle fois sur l'un des
aspects les plus importants de ce texte
nous avons nous soulignons la volonté de
madame le rapporteur de conserver
l'ajout du crime ou de l'agression
sexuelle commise sur la personne de son
enfant à l'article 378 2 du Code civil
toutefois cet article prévoit dans sa
rédaction actuelle une limitation de la
suspension de l'autorité parentale à un
délai maximal de 6 mois et si nous
comprenons les inquiétudes soulevées en
commission à propos de la présomption
d'innocence nous insistons sur
l'importance de supprimer ce délai
maximal quand on a parlé tout à l'heure
de d'instrumentalisation et de
et de culture qui était derrière ce type
de de mesures et pour nous il est
fondamental que cette suspension ne soit
pas remis en remise en cause jusqu'à
l'extinction des poursuites c'est une
manière de protéger l'enfant et d'éviter
l'instrumentalisation merci
merci chers collègues donc maintenant
c'est à la rapporteur de nous présenter
la vie de la commission sur les 8
amendements
merci monsieur le Président je vais
prendre si vous le permettez un petit
peu de temps sur sur le premier parce
que en fait l'article premier il est
quand même assez compliqué donc
l'amendement de numéro 22 de Madame
Cohen vise avant toute chose donc à
suspendre non pas l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale mais l'autorité
elle-même c'est-à-dire la titularité
l'autorité parentale ce qui change
totalement la nature de cette suspension
tout en maintenant une durée qui
pourrait aller jusqu'à plusieurs années
le temps de la procédure pénale donc le
but de cette modification vise à couper
le temps de la poussière pénale tout
lien avec l'enfant et à ce que le parent
poursuivi ou mis en examen ne soit plus
informé du devenir de son enfant en
effet celui qui n'exerce pas l'autorité
parentale conserve le droit et le devoir
de surveiller l'entretien et l'éducation
de l'enfant il doit être informé des
choix importants relatifs à la vie de ce
dernier en application de l'article
73-2-1 du Code civil donc l'amendement
vise également à intégrer dans le champ
de la procédure de suspension provisoire
de plein droit ils atteints de sexuels
incestueuses ce qui recouvre
l'exhibition ou le visionnage de films
pornographiques en présence de l'enfant
enfin l'amendement réintègre un
dispositif de suspension provisoire de
plein droit qui est distinct en cas de
condamnation pour violence volontaire
sur l'autre parent sans plus faire
référence et une durée d'étiquité ou à
la présence des enfants étant précisé
qu'une partie des infractions visées
sont des crimes et donc rentre dans le
dispositif qui est proposé par la
Commission les modifications suggérées
vont donc plus loin que la propolis sont
de loi est que le texte que la
Commission a adopté le dispositif en
fait aggrave la mesure de suspension en
étendant son champ à des délits qui
porterait une atteinte donc
disproportionnée au droit au respect de
la vie privée et familiale compte tenu
de son caractère automatique et de
l'absence de toute intervention du juge
je rappelle que la Commission a souhaité
réserver la suspension provisoire de
plein droit de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale au seul cas les plus graves
donc les crimes et des raisons sexuelles
incestueuses et conserver les mêmes
effets limités dans le temps
qu'aujourd'hui soit une durée maximale
de six mois jusqu'à la décision du JAF
la rédaction proposée présente de
surcroît de nombreuses difficultés
techniques car elle mélange les notions
de suspension et de retrait et par du
principe que la suspension serait
prononcée par un magistrat alors qu'elle
est de plein droit et s'opère
automatiquement par simple effet de la
loi en cas de poursuite par le ministère
public ou de mise en examen par le juge
d'instruction ou de condamnation elle
n'est donc pas formalisée par une
décision qui pourrait décider à retrait
partielle au lieu d'un retrait total par
ailleurs le JAF n'est pas compétent en
matière d'autorité parentale il est
compétent dans l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale l'autorité mentale c'est le
tribunal donc si l'on suspens l'autorité
parentale c'est pas lui qui pourrait la
rétablir mais le tribunal judiciaire en
collégialité j'ai pris un peu de temps
pour cet amendement monsieur le
Président est favorable sur le 22 c'est
ça
ensuite
nous avons l'amendement 44
donc les amendements 44 rectifiés et 45
en ce qui concerne le 44 donc c'est
identique les deux presque au précédent
il vise également un suspend de
l'autorité parentale toujours dans cette
idée de supprimer tout lien entre le
parent violent et l'enfant est donc avec
l'autre parent donc j'ai mis les mêmes
réserves à savoir l'absence de
proportionnalité et les difficultés
techniques je rappelle que dans le texte
de la commission les violences
volontaires les plus graves sont
incluses dans le dispositif de
suspension puisqu'il s'agit de crimes
par ailleurs en cas de condamnations
pour violence conjugale de nature
délictuelle selon une disposition du
décret du 23 novembre 22 l'enfant
témoigne de ces violences est victimes
et donc la juridique son pénale elle
l'obligation de se prononcer sur
l'autorité parentale c'est le sens des
modifications que j'ai proposé en
commission qui vit justement améliorer
cet aspect des choses et à obliger les
juridictions à se prononcer dès qu'il y
a des lits sur la personne de l'enfant
donc notre boussole ici c'est l'intérêt
de l'enfant c'est lui qui doit être le
centre en matière d'autorité parentale
ensuite l'amendement 45
donc c'est un avis défavorable c'est je
peux considérer que que c'est le même le
même commentaire ensuite nous avons le
25 c'est le rétablissement du texte
proposé par l'Assemblée nationale donc
notre collègue
tout en gardant en ajoutant ce délit de
6 jours pour l'intervention de la
science et en supprimant la condition
relative et la présence de l'enfant
s'agissant des violences congales donc
la commission elle a entendu limiter le
jeu de la suspension président de plein
droit au seul infractions les plus
graves ce qu'on a expliqué depuis début
crime et des visages sont sexuelles
sexuelles incessue sur l'enfant et
conserver le même effet dans le temps de
cette suspension automatique que
maintenant afin que le juge soit
systématiquement saisi et se prononce au
bout de 6 mois en fait c'est la
contrepartie qui est nécessaire à
l'automaticité
par ailleurs sur le délit de six jours
qui reprendrait celui qui existe en
matière d'ourtenance de protection il
n'a pas de sens ici puisque la
suspension est de plein droit c'est à
dire par simple effet de la loi elle
n'est pas formalisée par une décision de
justice la suspension court dès qu'il y
a mis en examens ou poursuit par le
parquet enfin sur la présence de
l'enfant je suis d'accord avec vous
cette limitation n'a pas de sens
toutefois la connaissance a choisi ne
pas créer de régime particulier de
suspension en cas de condamnation pour
violence conjugales de nature déliteuse
il appartient donc à la juridiction
pénale de se prononcer au moment de la
condamnation sur l'autorité parentale
c'est le sens de l'article de 228-1 que
nous avons introduit dans le code pénal
à l'article 3 5
avis défavorable aussi parce que c'est
une variante du précédent de qu'il
s'agirait de rétablir le texte de
l'Assemblée nationale tout en supprimant
à la condition relative à la présence de
l'enfant dont on a déjà parlé tout à
l'heure
le
26 on arrive au 3 et au 27 donc c'est
contraire à la position de la position
de Canal J défavorable visant à rétablir
le texte de l'Assemblée nationale donc
pour des raisons de proportionnalité et
contenu du caractère automatique la
commission entendue limitée le jeu de la
suspension provisoire de plein droit au
seul infractions et les plus graves je
me répète et conserver la procédure
existante qui garantit qu'un juge soit
systématiquement saisi et se prononce au
bout de 6 mois voilà donc c'est une
contrepartie qui est nécessaire à
l'automaticité voilà
ensuite donc je vous ai parlé du 27 on
arrive maintenant au 28 chemin faisant
donc c'est en fait c'est un avis
défavorable parce que on sait en fait
que tout le monde n'a pas du tout les
ressources nécessaires pour saisir un
juge et je ne parle pas ici que d'argent
il faut comprendre aussi ce que c'est
que saisir un juge et tout le monde
n'est pas capable malheureusement de le
faire
voilà monsieur le Président pour cette
première ministre
du gouvernement sur ces 8 ans maintenant
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames sénatrices par ces amendements
vous proposer de créer deux mécanismes
de suspension de plein droit de la
titularité de l'autorité parentale
ou de son exercice et des droits de
visite et d'hébergement
premier mécanisme en cas de poursuite ou
de condamnation du parent pour un crime
commis sur l'autre parent ou pour une
agression sexuelle
incestueuse ou un crime commis sur
l'enfant qui s'appliquerait jusqu'à la
décision du Juge aux Affaires Familiales
de la décision de non-lieu du juge
d'instruction ou de la décision du juge
pénal
deuxième mécanisme en cas de
condamnation du parent pour violence
avec incapacité totale de travail
supérieur à 8 jours commises sur l'autre
parent lorsque l'enfant a assisté au
fait
et ça s'appliquerait jusqu'à la décision
du juge aux affaires familiales saisies
dans un délai de six mois à compter de
la décision pénale voilà les deux
mécanismes que ces amendements proposent
alors je vous rejoins évidemment sur la
nécessité de prévoir que le mécanisme de
suspension de plein droit de l'exercice
de l'autorité parentale et des droits de
visite et d'hébergement doit s'appliquer
au crime et aux agressions sexuelles
incestueuses dont un enfant peut être
victime en revanche il me paraît
excessif de suspendre automatiquement et
les adverbes ont beaucoup d'intérêt la
particularité même de l'autorité
parentale alors qu'aucun juge n'a
examiné la situation
en revanche
je suis et je suis donc opposé aux
amendements 22 monsieur le Président 44
45 25
concernant les amendements 3 et 25
degrés pardon et ceci j'y viens je
réserve un sort particulier dans la
temporalité monsieur le Président mais
je ne l'ai pas oublié je veux vous
rassurer
concernant les amendements 3 et 27 de
rétablissement de l'article premier dans
sa version
issue de l'Assemblée nationale j'avais
indiqué que cette rédaction me semblait
équilibrée pour des raisons
constitutionnelles il nous faut être
prudent il est impératif me semble-t-il
de limiter le mécanisme de suspension de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale aux
infractions les plus graves et aux
violences conjugales avec ITT de plus de
huit jours à condition bien sûr
qu'elle soit commises en présence de
l'enfant en cohérence j'aimais donc un
avis de sagesse je pourrais même dire un
avis de sagesse bienveillant sur ces
amendements pour satisfaire à votre
légitime impatience monsieur le
Président voici l'amendement numéro 26
qui supprime la condition de présence de
l'enfant ils rend selon moi les
équilibres et j'y suis défavorable enfin
concernant la durée de cette suspension
il convient me semble-t-il de revenir à
la rédaction votée à l'Assemblée
nationale qui prévoit la saisine du juge
aux affaires familiales par les parties
et non plus par le procureur de la
République j'aimais donc un avis
favorable à l'amendement numéro 28
merci monsieur le ministre
je vais consulter
le Sénat sur ces 8 amendements
successifs en rappelant
les avis donc d'abord l'amendement 28
qui fait l'objet d'un double avis
défavorable
22 au temps pour moi je me relisais mal
excusez-moi le 22 nous commençons donc
par le 22 avec deux avis défavorables
madame Cohen demande la parole
pour expliquer son vote ainsi que Madame
Marie Bay
taille de ce que nous a dit la
rapporteur concernant le l'amendement 22
qui peut avoir sur certains aspects
quelques maladresses et entraîner
finalement des contresens juridiques etc
mais je la trouve particulièrement on va
dire sévère avec les amendements qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas présentés par
mon groupe mais qui reprennent la
l'écriture la version de l'Assemblée
nationale qui me semble quand même plus
protectrice et en cela j'apprécie la vie
du garde des sceaux qui émet soit un
avis de sagesse soit un avis favorable
et donc j'appelle l'ensemble de nos
collègues à réfléchir parce que nous
recherchons tous sur tous les bancs ici
et bien sûr madame la rapporteur aussi
je le sais la meilleure protection de
l'enfant et donc je crois qu'il faut
essayer de bien faire un équilibre entre
les différentes propositions qui sont
qui et l'écriture de l'Assemblée
nationale me semble en cela plus juste
et plus protectrice donc voilà j'ai fait
une explication de vote à la fois sur
mon amendement mais sur l'ensemble des
amendements qui étaient en discussion
commune je vous remercie monsieur le
Président entendu est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres explications de vote madame
billon
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
j'ai entendu les arguments à la fois de
Madame la rapporteur et du garde des
sceaux je pense que on a un tout ça même
objectif la protection de l'enfance sauf
que à travers ses amendements ce qu'on a
voulu porter c'est la dangerosité c'est
à dire que on peut pas avoir une échelle
de graduation de dangerosité et à partir
du moment où il y a soupçon où il y a
quelque soit la nature de la violence
intrafamiliale il y a danger le nombre
d'enfants qui décèdent sous le coup
d'apparent un tous les cinq jours le
nombre de femmes tuées dans les
violences intrafamilales nous oblige
c'est-à-dire nous oblige à mettre tout
en oeuvre pour ses enfants pour
peut-être avoir ce principe de
précaution au maximum c'est pour ça que
malgré la vie défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur je vais maintenir
l'abandonnement mon amendement et je
pense que celui de Dominique verrière
sera maintenu également par les
collègues qu'il avait consignés je vous
remercie
je vous invite évidemment à aller voter
donc nous nous prononçons d'abord sur
l'amendement 22
double avis défavorables qui est
fabriqué pour
contre
qui s'abstient donc il n'est pas adopté
ensuite
non
est adopté puisqu'il réécrivent le même
article si l'un est adopté les autres
tombes
et il
réécrivent l'article complètement et
donc les autres les amendements tombent
en effet
donc nous mettons maintenant aux voix
les amendements 44 et 45 qui sont
l'objet d'un double avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement ils
sont ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre
s’abstients pas adopté
sur le monde 25 double avis des
favorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui n'est pas adopté 26 est-ce que c'est
le même vote
alors sur l'amende les amendements 3 et
27 qui font l'objet de la vie
défavorable de la commission et d'un
avis de sagesse positive dixit le
ministre du gouvernement je consulte le
Sénat qui est pour ces deux amendements
la franchise du geste facilite le
comptage
qui est contre
et pas
et nous finissons par le 28 avis
défavorable de la commission et
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
donc il n'est pas adopté nous passons à
5 autres amendements portant sur et
également sur l'article premier et en
discussion commune cela commence par le
9 présenté par Madame rossignol
c'est le président comme ces amendements
visent toutes le même but vous allez je
vais les présenter tous en même temps ce
qui me l'aura 10 minutes pour ces 5
amendements mais je ne prendrais
peut-être pas tant totalement et je
voudrais préalablement rappeler que mon
premier choix
UTT le vote confort de l'article premier
comme ce n'est pas le cas je m'autorise
donc et nous nous autorisons donc avec
mes collègues quelques amendements une
minute de votre attention le texte dit
que l'autorité parentale est
suspendu retirés dans le cas où la crime
est une agression sexuelle a été commise
sur la personne de son enfant ce que je
comprends de cette rédaction c'est que
l'autorité parentale sur l'enfant
victime et retiré
mais que elle peut être maintenue sur
les autres enfants de la fratrie ce qui
est déjà pour moi un premier problème
comment un père
prenons que l'exemple du père c'est le
plus fréquent qui a commis un inceste
sur un de ses enfants peut conserver
l'autorité parentale sur les autres
enfants ça c'est le premier sujet de
préoccupation que j'ai sur cette
rédaction ensuite j'en ai un deuxième
c'est le cas d'un homme perd de famille
qui commet des agressions sexuelles sur
mineur incesteuse ou non ça peut être un
oncle ça peut être dans le cas où c'est
incestueux un ami de la famille
j'imagine que beaucoup ici ont vu les
chatouilles soit le se l'enseigne
d'Andréa Bescond soit le film dans les
chatouilles qui est une affaire de
violences sexuelles sur mineur c'est pas
quelqu'un de la famille c'est un ami de
la famille qui viole cette petite fille
pendant toute son enfance
cet homme peut être un père de famille
peut-on imaginer qu'un homme condamné
pour violence sexuelle sur mineur qui
lui-même a des enfants continue
poursuivre l'exercice de son autorité
parentale sur ses propres enfants on
peut considérer qu'il pèse sur lui une
suspicion ou du moins une présomption
peut-être de
de pour ce fin de réalisation de
commissions voilà donc je cherchais
pardon de commission d'actes d'actes
répréhensible en matière d'agrégation
sexuelle sur le mineur donc tous les
amendements qui sont là vise tous à ce
que un homme
poursuivi ou condamné progression
sexuelle sur un enfant incesteuse ou non
ne plus plus poursuivre l'exercice son
autorité parentale sur ses propres
enfants nous avons cinq rédactions je me
suis dit qu'avec cinq rédactions
possibles pour le même but peut-être
l'une d'entre elles allaient convenir à
la commission aux garde des sceaux
pleine d'espoir je me dis peut-être la
même rédaction qu'on viendrait et à la
Commission et aux gardes des sauts et on
pourrait ainsi élargir la portée de cet
article
entendu que la vie de la Commission sur
ces cinq amendements madame leur
rapporteur donc neuf 8 10 11 12
alors on va me trouver peut-être sévère
mais donc là nous avons une série de
cinq amendements qui visent tous à
élargir les cas de suspensions de
l'exercice pardon
non je faisais juste une petite remarque
alors donc je reprends monsieur le
Président
notre collègue Laurence Rossignol
présente une série de cinq amendements
visant tout ça élargir les cas de
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale en cas de crimo-agression
sexuelle commise sur un enfant quel
qu'il soit pas seulement son enfant dans
un objectif de lutte contre la paix de
criminalité elle me semble aller bien
plus loin que les recommandations de la
civisme qui ne s'est intéressé qu'au
lien entre un parent et son enfant
l'amendement numéro 9 permettrait une
suspension de plein droit pour tout
crimes agression sexuelle sur un tiers
quel que soit l'âge de la victime ou son
lien de parenté avec le parent
l'amendement numéro 8 ferait jouer la
suspension automatique à chaque fois
qu'un parent serait poursuivi pour un
crime à viol ou une agression sexuelle
ou la diffusion et l'enregistrement
d'image à caractère pornographique d'un
mineur de 16 ans
l'amendement numéro 10 vise à permettre
une spirtion de plein droit pour tout
crimes sans préciser qui est la victime
ou tout allait son sexuelle commise sur
un mineur l'amendement numéro 11 est le
même que le précédent mais limité au
mineur de 16 ans l'amendement numéro 12
vise enfin à permettre une suspension en
cas de crime d'agression sexuelle
ainsiue quel que soit le lien de parenté
de la victime avec l'auteur l'idée
sous-jacente serait qu'une personne qui
commet un crime un viol ou une agression
sexuelle sur quelqu'un un moment numéro
9 ou un mineur les autres amendements ne
pourraient être un bon parent et qu'il
faudrait suspendre lire s'ils sont
autorité parentale dès les poursuites
c'est une extension qui n'a pas été
envisagée par l'auteur de la proposition
de loi et sur laquelle je n'ai pas
conduit de travaux je note qu'elle n'a
pas été envisagée par le législateur
puisque l'article 378 du Code civil ne
prend en considération que les crimes et
des lits commises sur l'enfant ou les
crimes commis sur l'autre parent il me
semble que ces dispositions élargirées
énormément le chant de la suspension
automatique au point d'encourir un
griève d'atteinte à la proportionnalité
plus l'on s'éloigne de l'enfant qui fait
l'objet de l'autorité parentale plus il
faut se méfier la solution automatique
et se rappeler que la situation de
l'enfant doit être examinée incrons en
fonction de son intérêt et par le chef
il ne suffit pas de punir le parent
délinquant ou d'appliquer un principe de
précaution de manière maximaliste enfin
je remarque que la référence au mineur
de ses enquis est certes la limite d'âge
qui est employée dans le Code civil que
ce soit pour l'émancipation et la
nationalité crée un décalage avec le
code pénal qui utilise la limite d'âge
de 15 ans pour la définition de
certaines infractions avis défavorables
bien la vie du gouvernement monsieur
ministre
monsieur le Président mais mesdames
messieurs mesdames messenatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Rossignol l'amendement numéro
9 si les mots
incestueuses commis sur la personne de
son enfance sont supprimés
s'entraînent des facto le déclenchement
de cette suspension en cas d'infraction
de nature extrêmement variée commise par
l'auteur en dehors de son cercle
familial un parent qui se lancerait dans
le faux-monnaillage par exemple c'est un
crime
perdrait l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale sur ses enfants
non non
mais où mais ça signifie donc où ça
n'est pas et pardon et il y a donc un
certain nombre de crimes le notaire qui
commettrait un faux en écriture publique
se verrait privé de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale j'ai donc
défavorable évidemment cet amendement
l'amendement numéro 8 vous excluez en
réalité du dispositif les mineurs de 16
à 18 ans qui ne seraient plus protégés
même en cas de crime sexuel les
amendements et j'y suis évidemment
défavorable
les amendements 10 et 11
des mineurs ayant commis une agression
sexuelle sur un mineur en général
ne serait pas à l'abri de subir bien des
années plus tard une suspension de leur
autorité parentale sur leurs enfants nés
bien postérieurement au fait si
forcément des favorable à ces deux
amendements l'amendement numéro 12 la
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale aurait lieu en cas de crime
quel que soit la victime qu'elle
appartiennent ou non au cercle familial
de l'auteur vous voulez là encore vous
excluez là encore du dispositif le
mineur de 16 à 18 ans qui ne seraient
alors plus protégé même en cas de crime
donc ces amendements me semble mettre en
péril la cohérence même du dispositif il
entraîne évidemment des effets de bord
qui sont particulièrement importants au
point que l'intérêt même de l'enfant
pourrait ne plus être protégé dans ces
conditions je suis défavorable monsieur
le Président à l'intégralité de ses
amendements
madame la Présidente à vous
si j'ai bien compris leur apporte leur
rapporteur et le garde des sceaux sont
des favorables je suis pas tout compris
des raisons pour laquelle la rapporteur
lait parce que c'était trop rapide mais
j'ai quand même noté quelque chose la
situation de l'enfance apprécie une
concréto je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure comment apprécie-t-on une
concreto la situation d'un enfant dont
le frère ou la soeur a été victime de la
part d'inceste de la part du Père
j'aimerais savoir comment une concréto
vous appréciez même avec simplement du
bon sens
le fait que un père
ça donne à des agressions sexuelles
incestueux sur un de ses enfants mais
qu'il peut continuer d'exercer son
autorité parentale sans aucune
restriction sur ces autres enfants je
trouve qui ne concret tôt la situation
des autres enfants est assez
préoccupante et dangereuse
ça c'est la première remarque et ça vaut
aussi pour vous monsieur une garde des
sceaux cette question là alors je j'ai
bien compris que les rédactions avaient
toutes des défauts toutes des défauts
mais si vous êtes sensible à ce que je
viens de dire et je pense que n'importe
qui peut l'être
je vous avais la possibilité de nous
proposer une autre rédaction
et d'autant que sur certaines des
arguments qui ont été donnés
volontiers sur le premier
ou j'ai entendu ce que vous avez dit
c'est un corbeau un peu de mes
inquiétudes mais sur d'autres
vous avez dit que il y a une suspension
d'autorité parentale qui pourrait
concerner un mineur et qui pourrait lui
être retourné 15 ans après quand il
serait lui-même par an
on peut dans ce cas là j'entends
superplexe mais bon je vois que vos
services hoche la tête donc j'imagine
que c'est consensuel autour de vous dans
ce cas là sous un Mandon
sous amendons rajoutons majeur
rajoutons majeur
à celui auquel vous avez dit ça mais
vous ne pouvez pas à l'issue des cinq
amendements que j'ai déposé vous
contentez de me répondre qu'on va
laisser un père exercer son autorité
parentale sur les frères et soeurs d'un
enfant victime d'inceste vous savez ça
me rappelle exactement l'affaire Marina
quand j'avais découvert que dans
l'affaire Marina le père continuait
d'exercer l'autorité parentale depuis la
prison sur les frères et soeurs de
Marina j'avais quand même choqué
beaucoup de gens et ben c'est la même
histoire qui recommence mais j'imagine
que dans six mois un an deux ans on
reviendra avec une PPL de jeunes CESU
qui dira ah il y a peut-être un problème
avec les frères et sœurs parce que le
père a continué des avoir en droit de
visiter d'hébergement tous les week-ends
et puis un jour quand il est sorti de
prison il a pratiqué il a pratiqué sur
ses enfants des agressions sexuelles
alors madame billon merci monsieur le
Président non je suppose sur l'ensemble
de ces cinq amendements
a priori je vous remercie à chaque fois
Laurence bénéficie d'un
de faveur en réalité à la fois dans la
DG et pour la présentation de ces
amendements
non non je sais c'est une
boutade
donc moi je voulais dire que j'ai
entendu la présentation de ces cinq
amendements j'ai compris que notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol avait tout
mis en oeuvre pour tenter de trouver une
rédaction opportune je comprends pas
lorsqu'on évoque la proportionnalité
parce que pour moi il n'y a pas de
proportionnalité et on est là pour
protéger les enfants donc la graduation
des de la proportionnalité pour les
agresseurs les agressions et les
victimes ça me dérange par contre j'ai
vraiment entendu le fait des effets de
bord et ça je l'entends évidemment donc
moi comme ma collègue Laurence Rossignol
je crois vraiment que ce qu'elle a
exposé mérite toute notre attention et
on doit réussir à trouver une rédaction
ensemble pour pouvoir éviter les
situations qui ont été décrites donc
monsieur le garder son madame la
rapporteur vraiment moi je vous engage à
essayer de trouver une solution parce
que les cas qui ont été proposés et les
situations auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés il y a jamais une seule
agression tous les cas d'agression il y
a des récidives donc bien entendu il
faut qu'on puisse outiller mettre dans
la loi les éléments qui vont permettre
de bloquer ces agressions et ses livres
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
madame la sénatrice Rossignol je vous ai
fait part de
ma circonspection mais ça ne signifie
pas pour autant que il ne faille pas
travailler ensemble sur ce que vous
proposez je je vous rappelle je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je vous ai
remercié de m'avoir remercié quand
devant la délégation on avait évoqué
la prise en charge des enfants témoins
pour ne plus qu'il ne soit que témoin
mais qu'il soit également considéré
comme victime je vous ai dit je vais y
aller j'ai tenu parole sur la question
d'un non présentation d'enfant dans les
situations que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure il faut y aller avec prudent
parce que évidemment il y a des
équilibres textuels
constitutionnel conventionnelle il y a
également la présomption d'innocence qui
n'est pas un principe
anecdotique mais travaillons ensemble là
aussi moi je comprends le sens de ces
amendements évidemment mais
c'est d'ailleurs pas une question de
proportionnalité
la madame la sénatrice billon mais si on
évoque d'autres crimes évidemment on
ouvre la porte à des crimes
je veux dire quelque chose qui n'est pas
choquant et qui n'est pas une
provocation mais certains criminels je
pense au notaire je pas pardon de
reprendre cet exemple mais qui
commettrait un fond en écriture publique
ça fait pas de vie un mauvais père ça
fait de lui un criminel qui mérite une
sanction mais voilà le lien entre sa
paternité la façon dont il exerce et les
infractions qu'il a pu commettre quand
même tout le monde comprend ça donc moi
tout à fait d'accord pour que
alors si si je veux travailler avec vous
et que vous m'écoutez pas bon alors on
travaille ensemble et puis on essaie
d'arranger ça
la navette oui
on essaie d'arranger ça après on va voir
comment on va voir ce qu'on va y mettre
on va peut-être enlever un ou pour
mettre un et puis on va trouver quelque
chose
non
nous restons oui madame ne pardon madame
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre moi je suis pleine d'espoir
depuis le début de ce texte je me dis
que votre attitude est engageante parce
que vous avez envie comme nous d'avancer
sur ces questions
maintenant que l'émotion est passée je
pense madame la rapporteur est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire tranquillement
les raisons de votre refus parce que
vous avez été très vite c'est vrai
sûrement pas bien intérieurement avec
des réflexions de collègues mais voilà
j'aimerais vous entendre parce que
autant je ne suis pas spécialiste de la
légistique et les différences qui ont
été pointées par le garde des sceaux je
les entends et voilà je voudrais
progresser mais vous madame la
rapporteur je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce
qui fondamentalement fait que vous
pouvez refuser ce genre d'arguments du
point de vue de l'intérêt de l'enfant
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant on est
d'accord madame la rapporteur parce que
très vite dans ce débat déjà j'ai
remarqué on se détourne de l'intérêt de
l'enfant pour parler de la situation du
père incarcéré ou du père empêché etc et
donc là non il s'agit des droits de
l'enfant et de son intérêt supérieur
donc je voudrais vous comprendre madame
la rapporteur
ensuite y a-t-il d'autres interventions
d'autres demandes d'explication de vote
madame Rossignol oui
voilà je vais retirer ces amendements
j'ai entendu la réponse du garde des
sceaux
je
j'espère donc je foi dans le fait que
entre maintenant et la deuxième lecture
Assemblée nationale on va trouver le
moyen de d'une rédaction qui fasse que
premièrement un père
ne peut pas exercer l'autorité parentale
sur les frères et sœurs d'un enfant
auquel j'ai la commune sur lequel la
commune inceste on est d'accord
dans la famille voilà
mais même dans la famille parce qu'il
peut avoir comme il y a un inceste sur
un de vous sur une nièce et je porte et
je porte à votre réflexion la question
des hommes
reconnus coupables d'agressions sexuelle
sur mineur comment peuvent-ils exercer
leur autorité parentale voilà on a vu je
pense qu'on a tous eu on a lu l'enquête
du monde il y a pas très longtemps on
l'a tous lu
on a tous lu la dernière enquête du
monde sur les viols par streaming vous
l'avez vu monsieur garde des sceaux et
la dérive des pères qui d'abord regarde
et après offre leur propre enfant donc
on a un petit sujet quand même là
donc c'est un retrait du 5 si bien
compris
entendu et nous reste l'amendement 29 de
madame haribet qui est présenté par
Madame Lebou Hérault merci monsieur le
Président donc c'est un abonnement qui
est porté par Madame aribet et notre
groupe par cette amendement de repli
notre groupe renouvelle son souhait de
voir l'article premier intégré à
l'article
378-2 du Code civil la suspension de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement du
parent poursuivi ou condamnés pour des
violences volontaires sur l'autre parent
ayant entraîné unité supérieure à huit
jours nous vous rappelons que toute
initiative législative visant à lutter
contre les violences intra-familiales et
qui plus est en protéger les enfants ne
peut faire l'économie de disposition
liant les violences conjugales et une
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale
la vie de la commission madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc
l'autorité parentale vous avez bien
compris qu'elle ne peut pas être
disjointe de la protection de l'enfant
ça va ensemble contrairement au
dispositif proposé par les députés la
suspension provisoire de plein droit
pourrait avoir lieu dès les poursuites
ou la mise en examen en face Hamon de la
procédure pénale et pas seulement en cas
de condamnation et quand l'enfant a
assisté au fait nous sommes tous
d'accord que le fait que l'enfant
assiste au fait ne veut pas dire que
quand il n'a pas assisté au fait il ne
se rend pas compte de ce qui se passe
Françoise Dolto disait toujours dans une
famille les premiers informés quand ça
ne va pas c'est le bébé et le chien donc
quand l'enfant n'insiste pas il sait
quand même il sait très bien qu'il y a
des choses graves qui se passent donc je
rappelle que la Commission a choisi de
réserver la suspension provisoire de
plein droit au plus grave donc crime et
agression sexuelle ainsi ceux sur
l'enfant au nom du principe de
proportionnalité donc là vous me parlez
des ITT depuis huit jours je connais les
ITT je les connais j'en ai signé les ITT
de plus d'huit jours on en fait pas
beaucoup et dans les cas des violences
conjugales est-ce qu'on signe des ITT
quand c'est uniquement une violence qui
est pour moi gravissime qui est une
violence psychologique c'est pas dans
l'itté ça on ne le voit pas donc pour
moi l'ITT de plus de 10 jours ça ne peut
pas être la condition sinequanone il
faut aller bien au-delà puisque la
violence elle entraîne des conséquences
psychologiques extrêmement graves qui
vont pas être notés dans cette fameuse
ITT donc nous l'avons souvenir en
commission il ne paraît pas cohérent de
pas inclure les violences volontaires
aussi directement dirigées contre
l'enfant
d'accord la vie du gouvernement monsieur
défavorable monsieur le Président donc
je mets aux voix sous feu demande
d'explication de vote de Madame Meunier
et de Monsieur plat
évidemment c'est amendement mais je
voulais simplement dire à la rapporteur
que je pensais comme vous que les ITT de
8 jours étaient exceptionnels sauf que
hier c'est le hasard du calendrier je
suis allée à fédération solidarité femme
de Loire-Atlantique et elles m'ont dit
que non ce n'était plus le cas les ITT
supérieures à huit jours était davantage
constaté de fait des violences
psychiques justement et de la prise en
compte des violences psychiques avec les
violences physiques enfin les médecins
aussi changent dans leur pratique en
tout cas c'est ce qui est constaté voilà
c'était une information que je
souhaitais faire partager avec vous
merci donc je mets aux voix l'amendement
29 qui a fait l'objet d'un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
à l'abstention et ne pas adopter je me
ouvre l'article premier il a donc pas
été amendé depuis le texte de la
commission qui est pour l'article
premier
[Musique]
l'abstention il est adopté sur l'article
2 nous commençons par deux amendements
discussions communes le 13 bis rectifié
de la présidente rossignol qui a la
parole
maman d'une part le retour à la
rédaction initiale mais le retour à la
rédaction initiale plus
l'extension
un autre enfant que celui sur lequel
l'agression sexuelle incestueuse a été
commise donc je vais pas revenir avec
les mêmes arguments que tout à l'heure
je pense qu'on les a épuisés donc
monsieur le ministre gardez soit compris
que avec l'autre amendement il y a aussi
celui là par souci de cohérence et donc
il est retiré
et bien madame Cohen
oui c'est un amendement
identique monsieur le Président moi je
veux insister sur le fait que il est
vraiment extrêmement important d'ajouter
le délit d'atteindre sexuel incestueuse
à la liste des cas dans lesquels le
parent condamné soit retiré totalement
l'autorité parentale on le sait on le
partage je crois les répercussions
psychologiques sur l'enfant victime sont
des astruses et il n'est pas
envisageable de penser que l'auteur d'un
tel acte pourrait continuer à exercer
son autorité parentale sur la victime
donc nous devons garantir aux enfants un
environnement familial sain sans
violence et sans violence sexuelle
incestueuse qui brise la vie des enfants
la cicatrice qu'elle laisse est souvent
un des libyles nous devons donc les
protéger de toute nouvelle violence
sexuelle commise par un ascendant un
ascendant pardon afin que leur
souffrance c'est que tout simplement il
n'y ait pas de place à la récidive ni à
la gradation des violences je reviens
que sur des éléments qui ont été déjà
donné lors de notre discussion de
l'article premier mais ça me semble
quand même important parce que si j'ai
le sentiment qu'on les partage sur tous
les bancs on a quand même après des
interprétations qui sont diverses une
seule violence sexuelle incestueuse peu
importe sa qualification pour nous que
ce soit crime ou délit doit appeler le
retrait total de l'autorité parentale et
nous souhaitons également contrairement
aux modifications apportées par Madame
la rapporteur qu'il y ait une véritable
automaticité de ce retrait de l'autorité
parentale et pas seulement une
obligation donc je reviens un peu sur
les choses on dit que la répétition est
pédagogique donc peut-être que ça va
porter ses fruits
la vie de la Commission sur cet
amendement 19 madame la rapporteur
donc en l'état du texte actuel de la
Commission se délit d'atteindre sexuelle
incestueuse correspondrait à une
situation dans laquelle la juridique son
pénale serait obligée de se prononcer
sur le retrait de l'autorité parentale
sans que le principe soit un retrait
total ce qui semble proportionnés à la
fraction concernée donc c'est un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre de la Ville du
gouvernement sur cet amendement 19
je propose madame la sénatrice un
retrait au profit d'un amendement qui va
venir qui porte le numéro 46 qui me
paraît
rédigé de façon plus plus adéquate
comme par hasard je sais pas mais le
hasard parfois fait bien les choses
[Musique]